un lieu en route vers la centrale
nucléaire de zappos ridja qui inquiète
fortement la communauté internationale
aux mains des russes mais encore
contrôlés par les ukrainiens cette
centrale est la plus grande d'europe et
le chef de l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie atomique songe même à mettre
en place là-bas à une mission permanente
on écoute son chef a fait le gros si
we are moving en avant nous sommes au
courant de la situation actuelle et de
l'augmentation de l'activité militaire
y compris ce matin il y à quelques
minutes encore
j'ai été informé des risques par l'armée
ukrainienne
mais après avoir pesé le pour et le
contre
on a décidé de ne pas s'arrêter pour le
moment
dis donc sous très haute sécurité alors
que l'armée kenyane fait état de combats
actuellement autour de cette centrale
comme nous l'expliquent notre envoyé
spécial à zaporijia james andré la
délégation est partie tout à l'heure on
les a vus se préparer ici à l'hôtel
depuis tôt ce matin son parti équipé de
gilet pare-balles c'est un convoi de
quatre 4 blindés il faut savoir que la
centrale dit de zaporizhya se trouve en
réalité dans une ville qui s'appelle
hainard d'art qui se trouve à 60 km à
vol d'oiseau d'ici il faut à peu près
deux heures par la route pour rallier
cette centrale est cette route
évidemment elle est dangereuse alors
même si raphaël grossit en montant dans
sa voiture a expliqué et bien qu'il y
avait eu un accord pour leur permettre
un passage sûr malgré tout cela reste
tendu il faut savoir que dans la zone en
question on a rapporté ce matin et
durant la nuit alors des frappes de
mortier 1 c'est le maire d'hénin radars
qui a donné cette information il a dit
qu'avec des frappes de mortier sur la
ville d'asnières d'art donc juste à côté
de la centrale et qu' il y avait eu des
blessés dans ces frappes du côté des
russes on accuse les ukrainiens
d'avancer vers la centrale ça c'est le
gouverneur militaire qui a été donc
installé avec l'occupation de cette zone
qui comprend un art godard qui a parlé à
ria novosti qui est un média russe
expliquant que et bien selon lui il y
avait des avancées de troupe ukrainienne
vers la centrale alors même que cette
visite se prépare et que et bien les
russes avaient déployé des l'aviation et
des hélicoptères pour les arrêter donc
vous comprenez bien que la situation est
très tendue autour de la centrale que
jusqu'au dernier moment et bien les
combats continuent la question de savoir
si le cessez le feu sur un cessez le feu
le temps que effectivement le convoi
puisse passer il faut savoir aussi que
nous nous avons essayé d'accéder à cette
zone nous avons essayé d'accéder à
nikopol et aux villes qui se trouve
juste en face de la centrale évidemment
on ne peut pas passer en zone occupée
par les russes mais là eh bien nous
n'avons pas être autorisés à rentrer
toute la zone est bouclée fermée aux
journalistes
jusqu'au 5 septembre